[Music]
did you know
the current usps was created in 1972 i
did not know that
i thought was it the tony express that's
new
yeah was it before it was before it's
called
the post office department oh now it's
united states postal service what's the
what's the difference
i don't know it just says congress
created usps in 1972 making it a
permanent fixture of the federal
government it became
a part of the government instead of like
a private company oh maybe that's what
it is did the phrase going postal come
from
crazy post workers yeah there was a
there was a mass shooter that was a
postal worker well they were overworked
i think is the whole thing
and then they got mad and then they
started and they did it and it happened
a lot or just happened a couple times
oh [ __ ] but yeah are you guys aware of
the usps
situation or is going through a
financial crisis
also it's entering into the political
spectrum in terms of
uh the votes and all that are they
technically part of the government
yeah yes so then how are they going
through a financial crisis well they're
not very profitable
this is the whole thing about it right
so so amazon
and you know all these different
companies have come in and kind of
basically took the thunder away from the
postal service
ups was like complete [ __ ] for a long
time and that's what
opened up the avenue for fedex and ups
to come in just do a better job than
usps did and then usps kind of had to up
their game because of the competition
kind of like when triple a came in the
picture and then now you have to go to
dmv to get stuff done
exactly yeah and then oh good sorry why
does it have to be profitable if it's
being funded by the government maybe not
lose money at least oh oh they're losing
man money and i didn't know this until i
read into the whole
crisis thing that they're going through
the agency so the usps
isn't actually funded by our tax dollars
like all the other departments
oh government they rely on the sale of
postage
products and services to fund its
operations so it used to be profitable
because back then they didn't have email
uh more mail coming through and then no
no amazon
no fedex yeah uh ups yeah easy whatever
happened to the other one that
did the dhl dhl yeah they're still
around
i like them they're colorful they're
yellow yellow and red
yeah they're still around them all the
way i think fedex was the first to
use flight and overnight and like in
priority
stuff so like usps was like too damn
slow so fedex was like
i'll get the job people didn't think it
could be done before fedex will i i get
it done
overnight
my dumbass thought it was the pony
express that turned into the usps
you know the pony express when they just
like ride from town to town and it's
like here you got a message i got a
message from martha you know what i mean
oh crazy from dia elena
but yeah so the last time the usps
recorded a profit
was in 2006. wow
as of march 31st the cumulative losses
are totaled to be about 83.1
billion dollars that makes sense well
they're in big trouble they're in big
trouble yeah
and so they pay the people really good
mm-hmm and then the retirement
the retirement so the retirement's
actually predetermined already when they
hire the people
but a lot of this is the problem with a
lot of government things
is that they can't move quickly to
change so like
for example we don't use stamps as much
and if that's their number one biggest
revenue
yeah and all these other things it's
what are they going to do that's true
yeah and they're not subsidized by
anything else
with the pandemic too now it's just it's
even further kind of pushed them
like no one wants to be at the post
office the worst customer service i've
ever had other than the dmv
also government run holy [ __ ] it's
because they're underfunded and then so
they're overworked underfunded
and then they lost their revenue but at
the same time they made these promises
that they have to keep
they have to keep paying them a certain
rate they have to keep paying the
retirees and all that stuff
all the way up the chain so uh
that's just a it's kind of like basic
economics right if there's no money
coming
in they're gonna run out eventually so
what are they gonna do
uh then we'll enter enter trump yeah and
enter
uh he hired a new guy uh to be the post
master general his name is
that name lewis d joyce does this for
have like stars on his uniform
yeah ah postmaster he's decorated
general
yeah of the posters of this so d
joy uh he is a trump donor so he's
he's a pro-trump guy obviously trump
hired him and uh
he is in charge now of fixing things at
the usps and what he's done
so far is to cut over time uh cut late
delivery trips
and cut other expenses that ensure mail
is delivered on time
which which is rendering usps to be not
reliable at
all and that is the biggest like that
that's the biggest like a backlash
against this whole
this move which is yes in order to fix
the
the the million dollars worth of losses
you're cutting hours you're cutting
certain services to
to have less bleeding but then at the
same time now everyone in the country
can't
rely on you to deliver the mail yeah so
a lot of people are
fussing about that and not only that but
now that the
the the the election is coming up and
you know there's a lot of people that
are wanting to vote
via mail and mailing ballots rather than
going in person
because of the pandemic um a lot of
people were saying well now with because
of this move that trump has done by
hiring this guy
we can't even vote and and and trust
that
our votes are going to get in on time
because of the whole uh cutting hours
and stuff like that
do the ballots only go through usps
good question i'm not too sure about
that but that
based on what twitter sound is sounding
off on it seems that way
well yeah because i i i read the vice
article about this
yeah and basically they they say that
the the whole thing is that
um trump is trying to
uh downsize uh sorting machines at these
post offices in order to [ __ ] with vote
by mail so that
they don't the states don't do vote by
mail so that um
or or so that he can fraud the election
is the is the
you can't you can't vote online i don't
think so that would open up a lot of
fraud it would be a
physical ballot yeah but then because
even the melon things like yeah we
register bank accounts and then like we
could register with a dmv
and we could do so many things online
that's super protected
like our government can't figure that
out like yeah even some of those like
crypto places things that you you gotta
like just 20 different verifications and
[ __ ]
they'll like straight up scan your face
on your computer yeah
i don't know when they when they
launched obamacare remember the website
ordeal it was a [ __ ] mess like i
don't know if i trust
them to set up a web page [ __ ]
why is their website and they're not
internet
they're buying the shittiest servers
yeah everything that they make feels
like it's from 20 years ago website wise
and they spend [ __ ] tons of money on
them like how much is it
i'm like yo i could have got a better
deal you didn't have to spend 100 grand
on that website dude you just could have
talked to me what the [ __ ]
and then it looks like somebody made
that website in 93.
fireside yeah like they just got a
template from angelfire
but this is a very fun conspiracy right
because it's like oh like um
they're gonna steal the election always
a fun conspiracy and then it's like
oh they're um because trump uh appointed
somebody who donated to him which by the
way is how political appointments
[ __ ] work they
that's what they have been doing
it looks very insider right so yeah that
looks juicy right and then the
sorting machines getting taken out of
these facilities looks juicy and then
it's like
did you see that they were starting to
take out mailboxes too
there's like truckloads of just
mailboxes so they're like our
accessibility
is gone it does it does kind of make
sense though because think about it
right like some places
the only way they the only service that
does go there is the postal service like
amazon doesn't deliver like if they're a
super rule like
there's no [ __ ] fedex trucks because
it doesn't make sense for them to go do
you think that the government's
chill with our taxes not getting there
on time then if we have to
try right we have to send them through
the mail no excuses
i know right they did give us an
extension because of the quarantinos
yeah but still i would like just
kind of like how about one year we don't
have to pay taxes
how about that yeah and for all the
people that are working out there how
about they just get a refund for all the
taxes that they did pay how about that
i mean that might stimulate the comment
economy how about that you know how
about them apple how about that
how about getting the money into our
hands so we can because you know we'll
spend it dude like you know what i mean
like the banks
they're just gonna invest it you know
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna buy a paddle
board
i'm gonna stimulate the economy i
guarantee you're [ __ ] spending time
if they give you
back everything that you put into taxes
or whatever
if they give you a chunk of that and
they're like the only caveat is
you have to donate to one
tax thing that would normally get taxes
so if it's the schools or the military
or whatever like you have to donate a
certain percentage to one but you get to
choose yeah yeah
the type the humane society yeah
i'll tell you it makes me feel like i
have i'm contributing rather than you're
stealing my money the department of
water and power how about that
i'll send it to you i sent it to war
directly to war okay
[Laughter]
i think that there's no difference then
that then people would just
emotionally invest into the government
and the
the things that we actually need it
won't be allocated you know like we need
missiles
we do we kind of do you know do we have
missiles i know but we need more or
something but we gotta keep everyone
else in check right yeah we gotta have
more missiles
it's just a it's just a necessary evil i
kind of think
there's just people out there like gotta
have more drones yep true
yeah this shit's been really [ __ ]
with a lot of small businesses which
really sucks so i have um
a girlfriend who has like a pretty
successful um
like fitness line and stuff and she was
hitting me up like hey are all your
like are all your deliveries going via
like shipments going
via usps are they being delayed and i'm
like i don't know
like i think so and she's like yeah my
she's getting delayed for up to a month
oh my gosh yeah so then all her
customers are like what the [ __ ] where's
my [ __ ] and she's like
we sent it out like the next day and
it's like a month delay
jeff bezels is like i told you amazon's
the best
yeah he's over there he's an evil
[ __ ] he's like um
i knew this would happen i wouldn't be
surprised if him and bill gates got
together and they created corona so they
could [ __ ] high-five each other and
be like
let's make money better that's the job
because you got to follow where the
money is right who
banked the most off of corona that made
like 7 billion in one day the other day
dude he made a [ __ ] ton of money man oh
[ __ ]
new conspiracy what they're aliens
they look alien right true i mean just
look at them and they confirmed this
year the
u.s government confirmed that alien
spacecrafts were real i love how no one
gave us but no one cares
we think we actually recovered alien
spacecraft new york times says it and
everyone's like
they're like well they're like well ufos
doesn't mean alien but they actually
said
these crafts were not created on this
earth
like where the [ __ ] uh so who created
them on a different one too crazy this
year already no one gives a [ __ ] maybe
they're just kind of like can we like
get over one thing before we start the
next emotional capacity right it's
limited
we just can't [ __ ] take anything it
is a lot man
for me all this new [ __ ] is just like
i'm in a black mirror episode yeah who's
surprised anymore any of this [ __ ]
true but that's why the alien just more
interesting because i'm like how do
you take us with you yeah how do we why
would you want to go with them huh
because why would i want to stay here
this is kind of cool
but you don't how do you know you've
never been there yeah yeah it's true
what if these aliens have like four
titties and big old booties
you want more titties they're like hey
joe we were taking you to our our home
[ __ ] planet no
oh who is this too much of a good
now you're talking my language there it
is you gotta have rings around you're
talking my language
[Laughter]
[Music]
trombone
[Music]
you